[Music]
my name is Paul I live in Singapore when
I'm engineer and I work at stripe if
you're not familiar with stripe stripe
is a payments infrastructure company and
today I want to talk to you about how we
use reacting graph QL so just quick
current disclaimer like what we're going
to talk about here this talk isn't
necessarily about what graph QL is and
why you should use it it's more about
how stripe uses graphic UL and why we
use it why do you think it's great so I
want to talk a bit more about that graph
QL and the modern product development
stack talk about some stuff that we
built that stripe with graph QL and some
unexpected cool benefits that we found
out the first very important Eric I'm
talking about here was developed by many
people over many different teams I can't
take any credit for any of this
yeah it takes a bit to do this stuff so
in the screenshot here on the left you
see just a little small part of the
stripe dashboard now the stripe
dashboard is the main tool that we use
what our users use to find out
everything about their strife account
you can look at some logs here you can
find out about your API keys make
payments etc it's a really important
tool and kind of the first thing that I
use are C and we have a lot of teams
working on this at the same time so it
really needs to work had gel together as
much as possible so here's our stack yes
we use flow don't at me but whatever we
want to talk about is the last part here
which is graph QL and Apollo which is
kind of new for a stack so there Nardo
earlier or decay like a really good
little run-through of graph go I'll make
this really brief so first of all kind
of get by a show of hands obviously
everyone here has now heard of graph QL
but who is actually use graph QL here
okay enough people first to not be super
obvious right so on the left hand side
you see we have a more traditional REST
API recipe has great but graph QL is an
API technology you know it works in
terms of a schema instead of defined
endpoints so everything you see on the
left hand side and authors and posts
I instead have a schema sprayed here on
the right so one of the big benefits of
graph QL has ever showed earlier is that
it prevents over fetching Raul for REST
API where I don't know exactly what data
I'm getting back where graph QL I
explicitly tell the backend what I want
and it gives me exactly what I want and
I'm like having to have one URL or sorry
instead of having multiple URLs for rest
I only have one for sauce graph QL
endpoint which is great so how do we
make product development better at scale
it's the ad scale part here which I'm
really interested in the kind of
traditional product development looks a
bit like this right you have a front end
you have a back end and you have an API
which lets you talk to one another
that's what the ideal situation would
look like but in reality it looks more
like this there's a lot going on here
especially at a modern JavaScript
ecosystem even I even have two backends
here which is becoming more popular how
do you make sure all these parts
communicate with one another the most
valuable systems are those that can tie
into all these aspects of development so
for example a UI component system so
what we've done that stripe is we've
kind of replaced these middle two bits
with Apollo cogent and graph QL API and
the best thing about this that means
that all these components here can now
talk to one another using the same
format in the same data which in this
case is graph QL so all these things
know how to talk each others share the
data so as graph car has such a big
impact well schema defines capabilities
queries defined data requirements from
this schema here on the Left I can
command into on the right even gets a
little auto completion as you can see
here and I can reduce over fetching of
data I can have accurate monitoring this
is something I'll talk a little bit
later and we have a really good mocking
system here's a couple of more big
impact stories with graph QL what I want
to highlight here really is monitoring
in graph QL you can track usage for a
specific field this is traditionally
been a very difficult thing to do it in
a REST API you don't know what fields
are actually being used when fetched
from your back-end that's really hard to
do I'm going to talk about other marks
on them things in a sec servers let's
took a look some of the tools that we
built that stripe
first data mocking so why would you mock
stuff it seems like you know obvious why
we'd mock but it's really good to kind
of steady text back take step back and
really think about it so when you mock
self you have faster more resilient
chest you don't have to wait on an API
you have immediately test results you
can avoid the waterfall flow by actually
being able to develop your front-end
components before the backends even
built when you mock stuff and it's
really easy to generate educate States
so graph code makes mocking really easy
because we have a schema and the schema
has types in it we already know what
shape our data's going to look like and
exactly what type is gonna look like so
this is actually the code snippet I
grabbed from the graph to our tools on
the Left I have a schema string on the
right I'm actually I'm mocking it with
admonished the schema function I have my
query and I was as a result I have the
data with just some generic data based
on those types but the problem here is
you know what about edge cases right if
I have a globally mock schema which is
what what we're looking for what about
these little edge cases well
traditionally what you would do is you
would have perv request mocking its
means that for all my edge cases I would
have a request and a response and I'll
have the exact response here this is
nice this is good but now I'll lose all
the benefits of my schema base mocking
so what we do at stripe is we try to
have the best of both worlds where we
have overrides this means that I have my
generic data which created from my
schema but I can override some things so
I can test for for a specific edge case
over here my customers overs is the
function that we wrote which actually
lets me add extra data this is just a
simple to-do list all I care for this
particular to-do list is that there is
two items one that is completed and one
that is not everything else has been
mocked
which means that when I run my code and
I test it I know exactly what I'm
testing for so here's like an example of
these default marks in this case I have
this connect overview page react
component this actually takes a lot of
props and a lot of data but in this test
I don't care about what kind of data
goes in I just care that it renders and
then it doesn't it break or anything so
with global mocking by the SQL I
actually have a lot of props are being
passed into this component via Apollo
test provider and I
very easily check does this work or not
his example of the same except we're
using overrides now so I now have this
custom resolver where I can add like
things like a currency availability
pending etc and I can test for exactly
that what I'm interesting at the very
bottom without having to worry about all
the other props that are put into this
particular component we also have some
nice mocks for a really common edge case
which can be reducing quite difficult to
test which is error states and loading
States so here I have an error provider
and I have a loading provider which
keeps those components in a perpetual
state of are the loading or error so you
can very easily see what your users will
see if something goes wrong next don't
talk about schema validation and this is
something that's really important very
dear to us at stripe because we are have
grow it into a larger company where we
have many people working on the same
thing so when you make a small focused
API change I want to make sure that I
don't break a hundred other components
from scratch out about our component
base in a component system because it's
really easy to do that because of the
very nature of that component and Hana
hereditary system so we need guardrails
were able to do this what's really hard
about like that stripe dashboard is that
we do have a lot of people who work on
the same project who don't necessarily
see each other in person because we have
a global distributed teams so how do we
coordinate all these people build this
thing especially across multiple time
zones so that we have like a guardrail
well so I'm going to talk about a little
bit more about this in a sec but
generally we have a one schema graph QL
file we can generate flow types
automatically and we have a backwards
compatibility check er so first all of
our graph QL our whole schema is in one
file it's checked into our mono repo
it's automatically generated by our API
code and everything that we need like
this is the source of truth for all our
data that goes from the back end to the
front end and what's cool about this is
that as you can see here every single
item here in this address has a type
associated with that what can we do with
that well with Apollo coach and tools we
can actually generate flow types on the
fly automatically everything that comes
from the schema
now has an automatic types set to it
which makes developing a lot easier this
is really cool so what we build at
stripe is something called krory wrapper
this is a function which takes an owner
in this case the T though is responsible
for this code and it takes a query this
is just a normal graph QL query and it
says exactly what data that I want for
this component and it gives me back I
ready to use react component here it is
in use when I try to render it I have
some props I have a loading state I have
an arrow state and I have data and this
data object is just what I specify what
I wanted in the previous graph QL a
query so this is a really nice and easy
way to get my profs and my corners up
running fast as possible but we need a
backwards compatibility checker why do
we need this well we found that at
stripe sometimes people do not refresh
their front-end ever and one instance we
have someone who took over a month
before they refresh their pages and we
want to make sure that even those people
who do like to close tabs you know who
you are want to make sure that they
don't have a bad experience with if they
try like an operation and they get the
front end gets back data wasn't
expecting you get errors not good so we
actually have built this into our CI
component where if you change the schema
in any way it yells at you and says
don't do that but then you say okay well
how do you actually make breaking
changes then how do you how do we
actually add stuff to this well
sometimes we don't want to fields and
your effort no one's using we can have a
simple two step process we mark a field
as deprecated and we delete it merge
sorry we mark applies field as
deprecated then we merge and that one's
for sure that no one's using their field
anymore which we can do via monitoring
with graph QL we can just delete it this
is not ideal for things like modifying
an existing field but we're working on
things like that next I will talk about
just the benefits we've seen from
adopting graph QL so if you've ever read
about graph QL I've ever seen a video
you see like these common benefits which
we absolutely agree with these are
fantastic but it is over fetching you
know not having too many queries to
worry about these are all fantastic but
I want to talk more about what we at
stripe have really found has been really
beneficial about
using graph QL at scale which can be
somewhere in great tools and community
easily add stuff and those static types
first I just want to talk about the
tools and Docs
so because graph QL an Apollo coach n
are open source communities a lot of
work goes into this stuff as much as we
love the very proudly internal tooling
we have every two we build in-house is
something we have to maintain ourselves
by using graph QL there are many large
companies that are using this it kind of
takes the strain off of us
and they're just fantastic documentation
to be had with graph QL as well one of
the best things about graph QL is that
if you have heard of graphical and have
used in a previous job if you start work
at stripe you already know how stripes
front-end works because it's exactly the
same way it was before and finally the
real big benefit we've seen is just the
automatically generated static types so
this we use flow internally however this
will work with typescript as well it's
just really nice to have a component
with data and know exactly what types
those data is and it makes really easy
to review code gives you more or less
unintentional side effects and you can
modify a couple of so much faster same
conclusion I promise this would be short
because I know we're holding up lunch
right now graph kill works across the
stack at scale really nicely it's makes
everyone happy it's lets you well that's
all your developers kind of work in
unison and touch the same code without
getting stepping on each other's feet
makes testing easier and what's really
nice is just how quickly people can ramp
up and start developing with graph QL
and I promise I was not paid by Rothko
to say these things i generally do you
think it's a fantastic service right
with that thank you so much for having
me please do check out stripe dev and
come to our workshop which is hopefully
starting in about an hour's time
you